now white patients like this baby are
the default when it comes to medical
training in fact one recent u.s study
found that in some medical books only
four percent of images have black skin
but this is what medical texts could
look like if one nigerian medical
student has his way dw's west africa
correspondent flores dukuro reports from
lagos
this is lagos university teaching
hospital generations of doctors nurses
all kinds of medics have studied here
and this is one of the books that they
use it's a standard textbook used by
international students all around the
world and if you flip through the pages
it's very easy to see that most of the
illustrations here are just of white
skin it's almost as safe black people
don't have operations or don't have
babies and for years no one really
challenged that i met with one man who
not only challenged it but is doing
something about it
chidi berra ebay did this
his illustration of a black fetus went
viral
people around the world realized they
had never seen themselves represented
that way
his picture turned into much more than a
drawing
it was more like a voice speaking out
for the black community then i had to
understand that this drawing was more
than just a medical illustration or it
was a message of hope to to the black
community and then i said for me now
these drugs are no longer a passion but
a purpose for me so
i mean i had to turn from being just an
illustrator to being an advocate a lot
of patients have been misdiagnosed
because
there's been lack of representation in
medical literature for example some skin
conditions represent differently on the
black skin than eats on as it is on on a
white skin and that has led to a lot of
misdiagnosis
on on the side of the doctor because he
or she had no experience or have no
technical know-how on how to diagnose
this kick content on the black patient
and this one reason why representation
matters because if we work towards
including more of a diverse drawing
medical textbook medical student in
training will be more exposed to these
drawings and would have the experience
in treating patients
ebay has been inundated with reactions
from black communities around the world
we showed his pictures to medical
students here in lagos
yes african yes melanin
most of the clinical conditions we see
in textbooks are usually for white
people for example the russians you
talked about in white people usually
pink so then if i go to the hospital if
i start my clinicals i might be looking
for pink ratchets is not pink in
black people so i feel this and many
more medical conditions relating to
black people who actually go a long way
in the medical community especially in
africa
so once we start using our black people
once we see this kind of thing once we
read it in facebook there will be like
um differences between what we read in
our textbook and what we are seeing in
our gross anatomy lab so it should
actually help us to like understand it
better
since ebay's picture went viral he says
several publishers have commissioned him
to draw more black medical illustrations
he says he plans to publish his own
textbook on skin conditions in black
people
and wants to set up a training school
for other african medical illustrators
you